we're going to develop so that was
something that you did last week to look
the competitors before this is your
formula let me try to play why we're
doing it in a separate thing okay
look back at this question you did just
now about $850 and 45% prime for that
number of you this is simple interest
which means that each year that you've
got an advance and you're doing it for
time you get that much interest it's the
same every single time
okay so in fact if we change this and
make this just one it wouldn't be on a
judo Aikido area quarter so guess you're
going to be $29.25 similar check that I
did 19 divided like Rolling Stone but
it's going to like mix with fatigue okay
575
I just the wrong way around okay so
you've got this and then the more years
you add on you just keep on adding this
up again again and again which is why if
you multiply by four you just go back
when you started you have a good night
Keith right compound interest so you
already know it doesn't work like this
it doesn't give you the same amount over
and over again for however many years
how does it differ so I want to explain
the way the compound interest is
different yeah okay
can we go with this amount of money
can we just say we had yes then what
happens differently with this one that's
perfect okay but I actually wanted to
write down the words of course list what
Kate just said okay so under here what
you write down remember if we were to
change this from a simple interest bank
account to compound interest messenger
what we're going to do is we're going to
take after the first cue and I hope you
remember doing this in your work yeah I
do it be or do you say all right at the
end of the first year I've got the
original 850 and then I've got this
extra bit of interest that I calculated
so I'm just going to add them up at the
end of that year we'll have eight
hundred and seventy dollars and
twenty-five cents and ever suggested
rather than add 29/35 again Becky on
turn on 25 year after that and so on
I'm now going to recalculate the
interest off of this larger amount so
what I'm going to do is I want to say
look I will have the principal that's
eight seventy nine seventy five and then
I'm also going to have the new amount of
interest now can you help me work out
what was a new about the interest be you
can do it just like simple interest rate
it's going to be principal times the
rate times the number of years what's
the principal now at this point time yes
that's it your isn't it a $79 seventy
five what's the rate it's a stripper
five percent I do like writing it as a
decimal by the way I think that's a good
skill to practice there you go there's a
three point five percent what's the end
what's whatever it is it's just one year
I'm just like fun to you to the second
okay now before you go ahead
the arts are I want you to do as we've
seen in algebra before there's a common
factor between these two things you
notice that there's the first time I'm
here and there's the second time over
here but there's a huge color back up in
between both of them which is the eight
hundred and seventy nine dollars and 35
cents right the principal so I just want
to write down out the front eight seven
nine seven five one on 0.035 that's what
I've got in there after I take out the
fencer are you reading size up
now just before we leave I'll be fine
and actually calculate it
remember this plot is the principal just
one lobby add another principal bag and
this part represents future okay captain
will work out what the numbers
surely where the design hundred spider
ten thank you okay
now I could do this again for the third
yeah but again I'm going to drink it all
over again but with a new principle
right and I'm going to have to
recalculate the principle every single
time but this is starting to get a
little bit tiresome right and the more
years I have to do this but more
frustrating again so that's why we're
developing this or you might want you to
go to easily edit and I actually want
you to check out the word formula
because all we're doing okay actually
not a share and clocked out is we're
going to develop a shortcut for this
that's what most formulas are it's not
something as well we want you to
remember something hard than sigh this
could be crammed into your brain which
try to save you time this process is
generally slow and repetitive so is
there some way we can shortcut the whole
process how can we go straight to for
you or 40s
I mean people smash the key is this like
year see I factorize it to you were
probably thinking why do we factorize
you could just put this into your
calculator just like you want to got the
era would it be correct this slide is
the key here's what I'd like you to
write under a compound interest formula
this number at the fraud video eight
hundred seventy nine dollars and seventy
five cents it represents the principle
your green-themed for principle Josh the
American you started it got it so loud
no then i Specter us right so P is on
the outside the bracket what's on the
inside
well I am never might need to trade but
in addition through the interest rate I
bought the one like what does that
wonderfully what I have one least one
represent you start with the principal
and then you add on the interest does
that make sense every single year and
start with the principal
yeah the interest then you start with a
principal again you add on interest now
we were doing it one year at a time but
if I'm going to do it what to look for
these all I have to do is I don't write
the dances another if I want to do a
double year I would multiply by 152
straight again right just like I did it
here into a compared to 14 I want to do
it again I would just multiplied by 1
plus R repeatedly but if you get Tyson
right what's a quicker way to like this
you like square root of Q Rius yeah so I
can just write this weekend expectation
we're really good at index especially
the keys would have been arrested and
what I'd like you to follow a little
zhuzh
I'm going to raise this to a power the
number of years are you doing it is that
as x and like a different simple
interest I'm raising to the power I
could just put a four there and that
would show you what happens on 40 now
this is the compound interest for now I
want you to look at it and then I want
you to look at it next to the simple
interest formula if I'm not even going
to write out indeed they are remarkably
similar what is the typical area okay
now I want you to notice how similar
they are they all have the same set of
three numbers or three letters right you
need the principal you need to work out
should equipment a little consistent you
need to know it interest rate and then
you need to learn how long is that stop
in the bank you can fall right so very
very soon they're taking the same
ingredients and the work but he's a
difficult a highlight this is actually
not gonna fall to wish for you because
there's something on the other side like
an alert it's easy right so the question
I answer the beanie how its interested
in speed or burn gallium Jana Despoiler
just cavity right whereas this guy up
here does not give you interest look see
that doesn't be interested you could
that's the whole note that it's work
after two years right so actually this
is not I equals but a equals what we be
is it's the total amount
if you guys I get my statement in the
mail still we usually mystery we're
going to but you know but you have two
numbers right of the bottom of your bank
paper one of the numbers is how much
interested you earn this month quarter
however often you get them and as a
final number is this one so how much do
you actually have that you can draw if
you wanted to take so these two numbers
are different and people often miss the
fact that they're calculated to
differences so you've got the total
amount of computation and then you've
got the interest earn for simple
interest